[Music]
many years before that one of the boys
came down with the pot a fellow and said
if he made it through the night he'd
live but it would be a very long night
[Music]
so I sat with him all through the
darkness listened to his ragged little
breaths his coughing his window
which point Jon Snow when my husband
brought that baby home from the war I
couldn't bear to look at him didn't want
to see those brown strangers eyes
staring love me till I prayed to the
gods
take him away make him die he got the
pot and I knew I was the worst woman who
ever lived
murderer I condemned this poor innocent
child to a horrible death or the Khazraj
Elizabeth a woman he didn't even know I
prayed walls southern God said to boil
it Adam there
none of them I'll be a mother to him beg
my husband to give him a true name to
call him stark and be done with it to
make him one of us
and he lived and he lived
and I couldn't keep my promise happy
Mother's Day to Jon Snow King in the
north long may he reign
so there's a long untold history of
Catelyn Stark informing Jon Snow's
character as well as we on to start the
show has not touched on we've gotten
some brief teasers but there's a lot
more material for those characters in
the books that lets you know why he is
such a good king and why he's such a
good leader
even though Sansa might not necessarily
believe it big controversy of season 7
does Jon Snow deserve to be king the
answer is yes yes he does but there's a
new round of the book giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video
they're for the enhanced editions so the
reason I included those two clips is the
one it sort of tees up Ned Stark's
promised to Lyanna Stark there's the
history of Lyanna Stark Rhaegar
Targaryen Jon Snow that informs a lot of
Jon Snow's history but the other part of
that equation is Catelyn Stark the
mothers that he knew was actually not
that great of a mother to him even
though she's a really great character
she definitely shine through the first
three seasons of the show and then
there's all the books story that the TV
show has cut out dan and Dave's have
said that they regret many times that
they don't have a way to bring her back
we can talk about that in another video
because Catelyn Stark as a mother is a
really great character
but she's even better as the second
iteration of her character you know no
spoilers just in case you haven't for
the books but most of you probably know
the stabby thing that I'm talking about
starting with the first part of that
clip Lyanna stark informed Jon Snow's
character in more ethereal ways
obviously there's his DNA it's a very
important part of the story growing up
he always felt like an outsider he
always asked about his mother Ned Stark
refused to talk about her with anyone
including Catelyn Stark the quote that
he gave the Catelyn the book says never
asked me about Jon he is my blood and
that's all you need to know and that's
about as well as he treated Jon Snow
growing up he treated him as well as you
would expect a father to he's not the
most openly affectionate person in the
world even though he deeply cares about
his family you know you see him rush up
to Lyanna stark you clearly see that he
loves her he starts crying so that's all
in him there but once that ended his
real job his watch began watching Jon
Snow
in preventing any disasters from
erupting over the truth of his parentage
so for those of you that are still
wondering what she literally told him
when she was whispering and said promise
me that there are a few things that
George R Martin is going to hold pretty
close to the best but mostly what that
is is her just explaining the situation
to Ned and how Rhaegar is his father how
he can't tell anyone
Robert wouldn't understand those are
some of the only words that you can pick
out from her dialogue promise me Ned and
Robert would not understand because
Robert Baratheon was betrothed to her
loved her fiercely or at least loved the
idea for that's a completely separate
thing great character something of a
hound dog with the ladies makes him seem
like more of a dirtbag when you look at
the reality of the situation even though
the rebellion in history painted is it's
really big figure Liana made Ned Stark
promise to keep John Snow safe keep him
secret because one she loved him did not
want her child to die but to because of
the vast ramifications and how much
worse it would have made the war because
where this is happening right here is
after the sack of King's Landing
this is after Jaime has killed the Mad
King after Ned Stark walked in and found
him over his dead body you remember that
moment in season 1 where Ned Stark sort
of throws that King Flair moment in his
face how he's a traitor he killed the
man that he was sworn to protect even
though it was the right thing to do so
Catelyn Stark resents Ned resents Jon
Snow even though Ned Stark did the wrong
thing for the right reasons not telling
her the truth
of Jon Snow's mother Jaime Lannister
exact same thing
it's so much easier to give people lines
like never ask me about Jon he's my
blood that's all you need to know the
one sentence explainer for Jon Snow's
origin don't ask like there's this giant
book in The Citadel that explains his
entire history I could give you the
giant explainer or I could say don't ask
so because of that Jon Snow grows up
with half of an identity not knowing who
he is even though his brothers accepted
him he was very close to rob he was
never particularly close to Catelyn and
even though you see that he's very close
to Arya he also because Sansa takes
after her mother a lot was not super
close to Jon Snow and as you see here in
season six as they reunite they sort of
come
together but still in her heart of
hearts even though Sansa loves John Snow
she still feels like he isn't quite as
worthy as he might be had she known the
truth of his origin but it all leads to
Jon Snow having this great imposter
syndrome where he just feels like he
constantly has to prove himself and he
is not worthy of the things that he has
he lives in Winterfell he feels like
he's part of the stark family but not
really he feels like he has to earn it
constantly so isn't that someone that
you want as your king as opposed to say
someone like Joffrey at the other end of
the spectrum who just feels like
everything is owed to them there are no
rules the world is my plaything you can
see from that Catelyn scene that I
included that the TV shows really tried
to present a more balanced approach to
Catelyn Stark like she wasn't completely
cold she did care about Jon Snow but
ultimately could not live up to her
promise but the book really tells you
the truth of the matter so there's this
Catalan chapter where she's considering
it where she says to herself
whoever Jon's mother had been Ned must
have loved her fiercely for nothing
Catelyn said would persuade him to send
the boy away it was the one thing she
could never forgive him she had come to
love her husband with all her heart but
she had never found it in her to love
John she might have overlooked a dozen
bastards for Ned's sake so long as they
were out of sight John was never out of
sight and as he grew he looked more like
Ned than any of the trueborn sons she
bore him somehow that made it worse it's
such a great quote and obviously now we
know in context that yes Ned loves Jon
Snow's mother fiercely just not in the
way we expected and you learn why it is
that Jon Snow was always underfoot Ned
Stark always made sure that he was
around so that he could keep an eye on
him and protect him like he had promised
to his sister Lyanna the crazy thing
about this is that Jon Snow growing up
felt all this he absorbed all of this
passive hate the Catelyn had for him and
even though they weren't very clear
about it during the first season of the
show when they're all still at
Winterfell in the first couple of
episodes you see looks on his face like
this like he always has these downcast
eyes sort of navel-gazing
he has this imposter syndrome
constant need to prove himself which is
why he pushes himself to be worthy so
much which is why it's so much more
meaningful when you see scenes like this
where the Lords of the North named him
their king
I don't care where he comes from I don't
care what his name is
he's my king the King in the north this
is all going to cause two really big
things to happen during season seven one
you know he'll continue to try and be
the worthy king that everyone says that
he is he'll still feel like an impostor
no matter what even when brand hopefully
reveals the truth of his parentage it
won't do much for him he'll start to
understand but he'll still have all
those years of feeling like an outsider
that's not going to go away overnight
but two it will also cause a tidal wave
of hate from the fandom for any
characters that say that Jon Snow is not
worthy of being king in right now the
top of that list is Sansa Stark and
Littlefinger so Littlefinger you expect
him to hate Jon Snow he wants power so
anybody who was named king of the north
it was not Littlefinger in thoughts a
little finger would try to backstab but
because Sansa is Jon Snow's sister you
expect there to be some sort of support
system so part of the drama will be
seeing how she reacts to that because
you see previews like this and you're
like okay very clearly there's some look
and sauces eyes like she is not really
happy with what's going on so let me
know in the comments what do you think
about Catelyn Stark as a mother to Jon
Snow knowing the truth of things in the
way she really felt about him is honest
as she was in how do you think that his
true parentage is going to inform his
storyline during season seven that
speech from the little bear is actually
really important because they're
basically saying we don't care what your
blood is you're our King but his
parentage really does cause bigger
ripples if it were to be found out in
the South King's Landing in the other
places in the world so happy Mother's
Day to Jon Snow Lyanna stark Catelyn
Stark there's this great untold history
I can't wait to see what the show spells
out there's still so much of the books
that George or Martin hasn't written yet
in the big reveal the Tower of joy
reveal is a very wins a winter type
story so you have to imagine that the TV
show does maybe like a tenth of what
George our Martin writes in the book so
you get 10 times as much information in
context for that back
it's going to be so awesome we're really
close to getting that first big season 7
trailer so as we get closer to the
premiere I'm going to be doing more Game
of Thrones videos per a week to be a
little more organized a little more
specific be sure to let me know in the
comments what you want me to talk about
you guys get to decide what those bonus
videos are about Sunday's will still be
a game of Thrones day but you'll
probably start seeing Game of Thrones
videos happening during the week too but
we'll say congratulations to select :
you're the latest giveaway winner please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details while you wait for everything
you can click here to learn all about
the spin-offs that HBO is planning
there's not going to be 4 separate ones
there'll be one spin-off but there's 4
ideas that they have and you can click
here for all my other season 7 trailer
videos thank you so much for watching
let's not 5 I'll see you guys tonight
you